hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
GameSpot here at the Ubisoft booth at e3
2014 I'm standing here with Andrew who
is a game developer for Ubisoft and Jen
who does community development who's
also a great friend of mine which is
exciting and we're here to talk about
Rainbow six siege I just got to watch
the live demo which was pretty
impressive
now as a game developer when you take on
something like Tom Clancy's Rainbow six
what goes into deciding what you're
gonna do for a new game while still
staying true to what people love about a
series for us it was always about
getting back to the basics of the
franchise really really going back and
exploring what makes Rainbow six Rainbow
six now what made the the father a
tactical shooter is you know what what's
what's the beating heart of the
franchise and for us we iterated for a
while and we went back to the basics and
we actually came to this brand new
asymmetrical gameplay which we call a
siege gameplay all about the attackers
versus the defenders the attackers the
Masters of destruction these guys are
all our destruction experts right they
place breach charges make new paths the
defenders know that the attack is coming
the assault is coming and they're all
about fortifying on the objective
preparing for the assault and we lose
saw this and we saw this game play and
we really we stress it to the nth degree
and we incorporated a brand new
procedural destruction system to give
creativity to both sides and this is the
been the backbone of developing Rainbow
six siege there has been a lot of
destruction that I've seen in this game
it looks like part of the fun is just
blowing up like a suburban house right
well yeah it's the son of the experience
and it's the center with player
creativity on both sides attack in
defense
the attackers can place breach charges
on on walls and floors and make new
navigational opportunities get the drop
on on the on their enemies on the
defenders side you actually take a shot
they usually take shotguns that they can
ambush enemies by blowing a hole through
a wall and everything breaks based on
the material it is so when you take a
shotgun you blow a gypsy wall it's gonna
break just like jibs and like throwing a
c4 the other side and getting the drop
in ambushing and trapping some people
it's been really fun and players are
really playing with it and doing new
things that we didn't even think like oh
my god that was the best play ever so
it's been really fun and yeah the
destruction is really really cool in
Rainbow six siege it strikes me as kind
of that Second Life that all gamers want
to have like you know you're looking at
your house and I could throw a bomb at
that wall
you know renovation exactly so you know
that you said that the decision was made
to really focus on multiplayer here why
was that so important for this game in
particular well multiplayer has always
been a really strong part of the rainbow
franchise and as we were to making it we
wanted to put the the player experience
for first in the game with multiplayer
and really kind of you know iterate on
that so that's why I'm the siege
gameplay worked really well because you
need you know attack and defense and
that asymmetry and again we we iterated
on it and we it was so much fun so we
just we have a pre-alpha build right now
and the multiplayer game mode it's a 5v5
hostage-rescue it with no respawn we've
been we've been testing and playing it
internally and it's been so much fun so
we just wanted to you show the world
what we have and that's you know we're
doing at e3 so we wanted to put the
multiplayer experience cuz it's been so
fun so far we focused on that first
well we talked to a lot of game
developers here at e3 but tell the
viewers at home what a community
developer does for a game but a
community tough developer does for a
game well I've been working since the
start for a year and a half with the
team making sure to build the proper
platform and tool so that the community
when they're ready they can hop on board
and have a lot of fun together and grow
into something really amazing and until
that what I have right now on the team
is my community basically the dev team
is the community so we've been running
like you play a lot together we've run
internal tournaments and it's so much
fun and it's so great when you win with
your team you get up and you're like
buddies are right there you're high-five
it's really fun and I think the
community will be able to do that
someday
coming into a multiplayer game
especially it's going to be really
important to have a vibrant community
for a game how do you see that
developing for Rainbow six what do you
think people can expect to find in terms
of the groups of people they're going to
be playing with well I feel like this is
an interesting question it was a long
and drawn-out question I'm sorry yeah
well I hope that a lot of communities
are going to be able to gather around
Rainbow six siege like I think that a
lot of FPS fans are going to be able to
find something for them there but also
tactical fans I think that even RTS fans
might be interested in this there's so
much strategy that goes into it so much
planning like we sit down we look at the
maps we make plans we draw like
between games we even like do like we
talk about the games without the game
being there it's a lot of fun it's
really cool well being that I talked to
you quite frequently I know that you
know this is something you've been
working on for a long time you mentioned
you've been working on it for a long
time as well at e3 you finally got to
kind of announce what you've been
working on and tell everyone what you
secretly couldn't tell them before how
does that feel to finally announce this
project you've been working on so long
it feels amazing like when we were
waiting for the video to go on the stage
I was just in my ship my chair for some
reason I was nervous as the video could
crash and there was no way it would
happen it was like oh my god oh my god
it was really really good and feels
great to be able to like tweet about it
and have people respond and everyone
everyone has been so positive so far
it's amazing and what do you hope people
are going to do as they start to receive
and take this in and look forward to
beyond this pre alpha stage Oh
moving forward really focusing on the
C's receives gameplay and stressing it
even more again we're pre alpha right
now as we continue to iterate on the
game and push forward on different modes
and different things were going to be
doing we have a lot of top-secret things
we have waiting in stores for fans so
we're looking forward to showing it
sharing more in the future what we have
in store great thanks so much for your
time guys I really appreciate it
let me know what you think of Rainbow
six by tweeting at Anna Prosser with the
hashtag game spot III
you